Skrattar du, förlorar du (You laugh, you lose)
Mannen (Man)
Får det lov att vara lite skratta eller förlora? Hmmm? (How about a little YLYL? Hmmm?)
Welcome, everybody, to my brand new show.
Season 1!
Season 2!
Season 3!
All at the same time. We're trying it out.
Never. Done. Before. The rule here is simple,
but I will try and break them down for you.
If you happen to laugh, smile or grin during this video you lose the challenge.
If you happen to laugh, smile, or grin in this video you also lose the challenge.
By accepting this challenge, smash like on this video and buy the G fuel with code "pewdiepie".
Now it's only 10% off.
Now I'm already gonna lose at the first one because I'm already seeing
Dammit stop it. Zoella is literally Brent. Brent from the office.
Who is this self loving and how do I call it, self loving and lacking of insight...
but still trying to act humble character and...
Let's just watch.
[Video]: "I' don't think of myself as famous."
"I just have a lot of people who know who I am."
"The word 'famous' just sounds really weird to me, because i'm just me, not..."
"Well, I was going to say,I'm not really interesting, but obviously well six million people..."
"probably think I am."
I'm not really that interesting but you know six million people probably think I am. I am pretty humble. But also...
So good. I love, I love her face as well. It's so perfect like
mmm
I'm just gonna say I'm not that, THAT interesting
It's kind of tiring all the time youtubers have to be so, uh, "No, it's not that big a deal!"
You know what she has accomplished is pretty amazing.
And, she has every right to brag about it. I think it's just uh,
those two sentences probably didn't work the best together and she probably sees that. But it's still hilarious.
Next meme. That's not the show Felix. Learn the rules. Check out my health bar. How is yours doing?
*salsa music by 4 year olds*
Cool I'm rolling. I'm rof-lmao-ing
Literally rof-lmao-ing at that one. That was too hard. Next clip!
Was that it?
Wow, this is really hard. What is his snow-SMR? That made someone grin someone lost a challenge in there at least.
[Video]: "We saw people in the streets ready to put 2018 in the rear view mirror and say hello to 2019!"
"We also saw this dog with a banana."
*inhale*
AhhhhHHHHH
Oh my god, is that a dog with a banana?
That's so random!
-"2018 in the rear view mirror and say hello to 2019"-
"We also saw this dog with a banana."
God. Damn. I need to bind that to my soundboard. Dog with a banana
That's so epic
Okay, who is it gonna be?
Oh boy, this has been a tough challenge so far. Thank you for playing along.
It turns out there's only five more contestants out of 80 million. This has to be one of the hardest toughest ones so far
Okay, let's
freakin
get going
guys.
"Five..."
"Four..."
"Three..."
"Two..."
What is this....?
"One!"
"Hands up!"
*cackling*
Yes!
That's it, everyone lost.
Children crying. No one can stand against the power of
children crying. Oh, that's beautiful.
Aw, poor child, I'm sorry.
Oh, that's beautiful.
It didn't even look good to begin with.
It's just like, what is that? I don't think it matters if that falls over.
I don't think that's working.
Oh got more help. Looks like I'm still in the game, guy!
Oh, I thought it was gonna break.
"Damn."
*more cackling*
Dead ass face as well. That's great.
Damn.
Moving. On. Yes!
This clip.
It's the greatest clip of all time. I love it so much.
"Who's that?"
I want a full version.
I want the whole... what is that stupid movie called...
like unfriended or something or is that a different version of that?
That looks different. Doesn't it?
Oh, looks like I'm losing.
You know, some people would say it's unfair that I could just drink G fuel to replenish my health
But so can you okay?
It's not exclusive to me just buy the G fuel code  "Pewdiepie" and check it out
Yeah, oh oh my
I like how you can already see the fake bind fake its fake, okay, not funny fake
Fake and gay the sad part about that joke is I'm literally raywilliamjohnson at this point baby changing station
Baby hanging station
Finally they did it absolute man. Let's next clip everyone
Oh, it's Annabelle
Jesus Christ is dragged out. Hi. Welcome to Chili's
Goddamnit, I'm not even trying at this point because I have G fuel. I don't have to anymore
It's more like laughs as much as you want challenge because I used the code "pewdiepie" to buy G fuel (smh felix)
get a bowl
Okay, fill it with water put some pepper and no water. That's cool
Put some dish soap on your finger
The reason this happens is because you're a virgin Oh
Did you just call himself a virgin? I don't think we need a scientific experiment to know that you guys are virgins
Thank you very much
aahhhh AHHHHHHHHH
*screams in imense pain*
smh
Was he actually playing Mario 64 was he actually? because this is me whenever I die in
Minecraft I don't know. Okay, Jesus Christ. What an epic freakout
*epic freakout*
Even know how to play that thing. Nope, but I'll never know until I try
of course... of course
it actually sounds lit
Toes oh I'm so curious. Is that a real commercial
I like that give it a 10
It gets a tip
We find it the best clip of all time
Oh, yes papa. Someone sends me this in the mail papa. It's a ring for six Popov. I know what the first
Who talks like that, how can you talk with such a strong Swedish accent?
pathetic learn how to properly pronounce your words and normal a
aahhhh AHHHHHHHHH
Ooo!
Almost forgot
Because
Um t-
Ooo! Almost forgot. On top of the. Sister collection
Ooo! Ohuh! Ooo! Literally. Almost forgot
Right now, oh my god, literally almost forgot. Hello
No, stop it. Speaking of James Charles by the way, James Charles called sneaks subscribers sisters
I've been calling my subscribers for many years broke and I realize now I've been
Tapping out half the market. I've only appealed to one gender how discriminatory of me the
I think
Everyone go tell James Charles bros invites sisters to subscribe to PewDiePie
I watched gellete  commercial and I've learned to do better now
So now Bros will help out sisters. So sisters can subscribe
Subscribe to pewdiepie sis scribe to pewdiepie. Do you want to see me die from t-series?
Cuz that's what's gonna happen. You don't want pretty pipe to die. Do you I don't have infinite G fuel, you know
Sis sky, the blue any pie smash like and subscribe in this video fired by the merch it's available for a couple more days
Thank you! Bye! Bye!